almost all cross-testing to kill or
pacify scp-682 had failed miserably
if you haven't seen it go watch our
video on the legendary hard to kill
reptile
to see just how powerful and terrifying
this creature is
it faced the gate guardian an scp with a
flaming sword hotter than the sun
capable of tearing your atoms to shreds
and came out fine
in its face off with the horrifying
scp-096
also known as the shy guy it broke the
shy guy's mind and reduced it to
jibbering despair
even scps with supposedly unlimited
powers
simply refused to engage the beast in
combat
so when it was proposed that they test
682 with scp-999
a creature known among foundation staff
as the tickle monster
the idea was considered laughable 682
had been burned
suffocated cut up incinerated and
growled in the faces of the gods
how could this so-called tickle monster
ever hope to survive an encounter
let alone win a fight some even believe
that this was the last we'd see of
scp-999
but what makes this story truly
remarkable is that that isn't how this
played out
as you'll soon discover scp-999 is an
amazing
and unique scp in and of itself but its
secret origins and its interactions with
some other prominent figures in the scp
universe are what make this humble slimy
creature beyond extraordinary
prepare yourself for the heartwarming
yes you heard that right
the heartwarming story of scp-999
several highly trained agents on 682
detail placed 999 into the immortal
lizard cell
compared to the giant reptilian sitting
across from it 999 wasn't much to look
at
it's a large orange amorphous blob of
anomalous slime
weighing in at around 120 pounds scp-999
was nothing compared to the monstrosity
it was supposed to face
while its weight has in the past caused
minor injuries to some of its human
handlers
it has never caused serious or
long-lasting damage of any kind to a
living thing
even its diet consists only of candy and
sweets with a particular preference for
m
ms and necco wafers it consumes these
treats through the cell membrane of its
slimy body
much like an amoeba this extremely
stretchy membrane means the creature is
highly malleable
including the ability to stretch and
flatten itself out to a mere two
centimeters thick
at rest the creature takes a dome-like
shape around two meters wide and one
meter in height
the closest things the creature has to
limbs are prehenso pseudopods
those are the arm-like projections
normally seen on single-celled organisms
of which it has at least three the more
you hear about this utterly harmless
creature the more that matching it up
with the pure embodiment of absolute
hatred known as
scp-682 feels downright cruel
in absolute contrast to the misanthropic
attitudes of the reptile
999 loves humans it has a playful
dog-like attitude
much like an overexcited puppy when
approached 999 will react with extreme
joy and slither towards the nearest
person in order to interact
it will leap onto them using two of its
three prehensile pseudopods to hug the
person
while the third nuzzles the person's
face emitting high-pitched cooing and
gurgling noises throughout
the creature is apparently pleasant in
every conceivable fashion
as even its odor has been reported to
smell just like the favorite scent of
whoever is smelling it
examples have included chocolate fresh
laundry bacon roses and play-doh
it's almost impossible to oversell just
how beloved and benevolent this strange
creature is
it's one of the rare sapient scps to
earn the safe class
and it's allowed to roam freely around
its facility at all times
apart from a one hour bedtime period
between 8 and 9 pm
in the rare instances that 999 has
caused harm to a worker at the facility
it immediately began to back away and
contract its body while whimpering in a
kind of dog-like apology
the closest the foundation has ever come
to having a real incident with the
creature was the time someone
accidentally fed it a can of caffeinated
cola
causing it to become hyper for an hour
before becoming visibly queasy
you'll be relieved to know that it's
since made a full recovery
but what would happen when this
whimsical creature is forced to go
toe-to-toe with the foundation's most
ill-tempered monster the employees
observing the test watched in suspense
as 999 began to enthusiastically slither
towards 682
it's no surprise that after being
tortured and almost killed hundreds of
times during testing
682 had grown jaded to the cross test it
was regularly subjected to
when it saw this strange orange blob
squelching across the ground towards it
it sighed and groaned expecting the
worst
what is that the creature asked of its
gelatinous guest
scp-999 began jumping up and down in
front of 682 like an excited puppy
creating a high-pitched squealing noise
just as it regarded all living things
682 thought the creature bouncing around
before it was disgusting
and hardly worth the effort to destroy
was the foundation even trying anymore
with a single vicious stomp 682
flattened the friendly creature beneath
one of its feet
observers were prepared to charge in and
liberate 999 from under 682's claws
but then something truly unexpected
happened the expression on 682's acid
eaten face
began to slowly change it was beginning
to smile observers recorded a noise what
they thought could have been a chuckle
as the creature growled and said
what is this i feel
good while the observers looked on
stunned at what was happening 999 began
to slither and crawl up from between
682's toes
reformed on its scaly leg and slithered
up along its side until it reached the
neck
there it began to nuzzle like it had
never nuzzled before
the results spoke for themselves 682 was
grinning and chuckling
repeating a phrase that the foundation
never would have imagined coming from
682
feel so happy
happy happy
happy just when you thought scp-999
couldn't possibly be more adorable
you learn about its greatest power
bringing joy
anyone and anything that comes into
contact with the creature even in
passing
will experience a kind of mild euphoria
as once contact with the creature is
prolonged this overwhelming sense of joy
increases
and continues long after you've
separated from it prolonged contact has
completely cured depression
anxiety and ptsd along with a number of
other conditions
including rage and antisocial
personality disorders
serial killers practically become saints
after coming into prolonged contact with
999
and in that moment 682 was no exception
and there truly does not appear to be no
exceptions
while causing happiness and joy isn't a
dangerous weapon when it comes to
scp-999 it is an extremely powerful one
and what's more scp-999 also appears to
have an innate sense for those who need
its help most
with a particular affection for the hurt
and the unhappy
the creature appears to be a true
altruist on a fundamental level
even risking its own safety to help
humans during dangerous containment
breaches
in one dramatic instance 999 leaped into
the air to block a bullet from making
contact with a member of staff
as a result the creature is pretty much
universally loved by all members of
foundation staff
it's the one scp who has never made
trouble for anyone
back in scp-682's containment cell the
beast was still
smiling and laughing as 999 rubbed
against its neck
it was an event so strange so
unprecedented that the observers in
attendance felt like they were
hallucinating
for a few minutes the monster kept
dreamily repeating the word
happy but then suddenly the creature
began to enter a fit of
uncontrollable booming laughter it
rolled onto its back
slamming its huge tail against the door
it had just fallen victim to one of
999's favorite pastimes
tickle fights hence how it earned its
tickle monster nickname among staff
the tickle fight continued until 682
appeared to tire and fall asleep
with a smile still on its face after 15
minutes of inactivity
two d-class personnel were commanded to
enter and retrieve scp-999 from the
containment cell
they did so successfully but as soon as
999 was removed
682 roused from its lumber and released
a powerful psychic attack from its
entire body
while laughing maniacally it rendered
all personnel within a certain distance
incapacitated
as they collapsed in fits of laughter
allowing 682 to escape and go
on a violent rampage however in spite of
this
999 showed no fear and helped save some
of the bystanders as security officers
subdued and recaptured 682
and even after all of this 999 showed no
hard feelings towards 682
and indicated a desire to play again
it's a creature whose capacity for love
is so limitless that it's practically
immune to fear
which is all well and good because the
true enemy that 999 is destined to face
is infinitely more powerful and
terrifying than 682 could ever hope to
be what is this monster
and why should 999 have to face it
someday the answers to these questions
all lie
in the true origins of scp-999 available
only to those with level 5 clearance and
beyond
it's a perfect example of how something
good can come from the darkest places
there would be no scp-999 without
scp-231-7
scp-231 was a collection of seven girls
all impregnated by horrific nightmares
in a ritual performed by a cult known as
the children of the scarlet king
each of these girls over the years that
followed gave birth to some of the most
horrific monsters imaginable
one of which according to some was
scp-682
these beings were manifested by the
scarlet king a powerful interdimensional
nightmare god believed to be behind a
great deal of the darkness and horror
present within
r and many other dimensions foundation
higher-ups have declared the scarlet
king to be the greatest existing threat
to the multiverse at large
and scp-231 was his latest direct
interaction with our universe
the only surviving member of scp-231
scp-231-d
gave birth in secret but she didn't give
birth to a monster
she gave birth to scp-999 a being of
pure goodness
that's right the nicest kindest
cuddliest scp of all
is the direct descendant of a being
that's essentially the dark god of
all evil feel free to take a moment to
absorb that
the creature even healed the girl who
birthed it and allowed her to return to
normal life with her family once more
from its first moments scp-999 was
making positive changes to the world
around it
and according to ancient texts from a
scarlet king aligned culture known as
the devas
scp-999 is still very much in its
infancy
yet it already has the power to pacify
its monstrous siblings like the
aforementioned 682
it's believed according to some
prophecies and foundation theories
that the power of scp-999 will grow
exponentially as it matures
why does this matter well it's believed
by some that one day
999 will grow powerful enough to
overthrow not only its own monstrous
siblings but the thought to be
unstoppable scarlet king himself not
through violence or hate
but through the pure force of happiness
and love burning out the darkness and
purifying the corrupted
while the humble scp-999 rarely
outshines its frightening competitors
to those truly in the know 999 is one of
the most powerful
and valuable scps in existence and may
be the greatest asset in the
foundation's arsenal for the war against
dangerous anomalous activity
after all what could strike more fear
into their hearts
than the knowledge that it might be love
rather than firepower
that finally dethrones the scarlet king
and for the knowledge that it may one
day save everything we
know from a fate so much worse than
death with nothing but affection for
everyone and everything
it's worth offering thanks to the little
orange blob or at least an extra pack of
m ms before bedtime
you